don't run me into something
what is this I'm so nervous what is
gonna happen nothing just wait for Noel
to tell you when it's
when it's blindfold
what is this
I feel like something's gonna come
attack me right now
what is that
what is sad
good morning
go and take that blindfold off brother
happy 300 my guy how are you
laughs
smells pretty good
happy 300. thanks happy 300 bro 300
episodes come here bring it in man hello
everybody
it's our 300th episode
which is [__] insane pretty insane I
was thinking that I was like how many
years is that six that's crazy yeah six
years man I wanted to get us a little
gift I wanted to surprise the show first
of all
we'll talk about the truck in a second
he didn't know how this came to be yeah
we'll talk about this in a moment
because it's sick yeah thank you do we
get to keep it uh we can talk about that
yeah we can definitely talk about it
okay all right so uh this is cool oh
hold on
ah [__] [__] sake dude
speaking of the truck and surprises I
wanted to surprise us
I don't think there's really any way I
could tee this up so what
a God no way
no [__] way
dude he's like like a moth to a flame
like a moth to a flame
I wish you guys could see his face from
this side
16 bucks 17 bucks 18 bucks keep it 18 oh
we got more flash this is [__] it's
[__] about right here this is such a
rush is it not you don't have to tell me
oh my God everyone listening is like
[__] no
oh you got to pick a monkey
respin and multiply oh [__] dude
oh no
oh
2x eight horse fans oh no this is what
it's about right here
eight more does not feel this energy in
here this rush I think it feels like
carbon monoxide
yeah maybe that's what it is maybe I'm a
little bit light-headed from the [__]
exhaust of this car
42 dollars
and that's how it's done
that's what a big win looks like that's
a stupendous wind dance right there oh
sorry big one this is what this is what
runner's high feels like yeah yeah
but way worse okay I think I'm gonna
start running then yeah do we get to
keep this this is ours
really this is ours the slot machine is
fully ours but the truck
we can make this ours
for the low low price of
we'll talk about okay okay and what is
this truck this is a k truck
k-e-i I love it all the way from Nippon
Japan okay all the way all the way over
here like you shifted over just for this
or our guy George specializes in
importing these so he imported it just
for the 300th episode uh yeah yeah
that's how wow dude shout out to you man
that's really it took two months so he
knew when we hit episode two yeah yeah
he's like I have to he was keeping track
I gotta make sure yeah I get this here
in time it's a sick Truck Yeah so so and
this
this does this actually pay out
oh yeah let me collect
two thousand seven hundred twenty one
dollars
uh 40 of that is mine I'll have you know
so uh where's the cashier yeah where's
the cashier I think it's us technically
I I actually got you a gift too did you
yeah yeah what is it
well it's it's also car related oh
really
yeah you went to Quality route okay I
veered towards the quantity route okay
okay holy [__]
foreign
wow this is good
that is 300 Hot Wheels which is if I
just nowhere near the amount I thought
it was going to look like
when I said 300 Hot Wheel Hot Wheels I
pictured it to be like you know like a
mound over the wheelbarrow but
[Laughter]
now we have now we have my biggest Vice
and Noel's biggest Vice on set happiest
day of Our Lives yeah
pretty insane
pretty insane dude thank you for the
300. near the amount I thought it was
going to be like heaping you know you
need like a thousand like I know yeah I
felt this is like this is like when you
first see like ten thousand dollars in a
briefcase and it's like a stack like
this egg and you're like ah yeah the
[__] yeah
everyone relates to that by the way on
audio they're like oh yes when I
received ten thousand dollars in a
briefcase
I've seen that myself I mean like you've
seen it in like a video or something
yeah it's like always in like comedies
Deal or No Deal yeah yeah exactly yeah
yeah yeah I'm kidding though I have seen
that many times
[Laughter]
so you're just gonna [__] uh I was
gonna say you're just gonna tease me
you're actually gonna rip one through
there we'll do it later yeah we'll do it
later we'll do it later man
um
so
it is a celebration right
it's gonna be making that sound the
whole time yeah it's calling your name
no just that just that yeah yeah it is
isn't it yeah that's that's the sound
like I was saying that like I was
annoyed but I'm almost drawn to that
noise yeah it'll it's fine The Noise
Gate will cut it out sounds like Freedom
doesn't it yeah well like you're
drifting through the casino floor
if we just load up we shouldn't because
it's not cool what we just lit up a
stove right now it's not cool to do it's
definitely not it's not all right to do
um it is a celebration so
I do think we deserve a cake okay
wait what
oh my God
give me that [__] knife oh my God
do it
we'll do the limbs first so that it
feels it you know
for people listening this is a uh this
is a cake that looks like a gigantic
Lobster and very realistic too
with the sand I do
I do let's see
that's how you're supposed to do it
right to the back of the head there you
go yeah put it out of its misery all
right now we can sit and smile
what a
If this just isn't the last six months
in an image
this is sick happy 300 everybody